[Music]
sheera told me at 70 she's not slowing
down at this point in a lot of people's
careers they're winding down you're
winding back up why because I like what
I do you know and I never knew there was
gonna be like a sell-by date
so at age 70 she's starring in a new
Lifetime movie titled Flint she will
play a woman affected by the Michigan
city's water contamination crisis she is
also an executive producer along with
Katie Couric where are you going now
this won't be the first time the chair
has tackled real-life issues on film she
earned her first Oscar nomination for
1983 Silkwood where she and Meryl Streep
worked in a contaminated nuclear
facility 33 years later she still has
that passion for social causes and the
energy of someone half her age I'm just
older than dirt you're not older than
dirt in your mind what do you think I
feel like in my in my mind I just
totally forget and the other day I
thought I was 16 I went oh my god I'm 60
and I thought oh my god I should just I
never expected to live this long
[Music]
before her new movie she's returning to
the stage with a residency called
classic share that launches at the Monte
Carlo in Vegas next month and moves on
to the MGM in the DC area in March you
like try to go do I still want to do
this you know and the one thing I know
is I still like to sing so much I love
to sing
[Music]
Oh